all right before we go back to talking
about John Bolton I want to talk with
you today about corporations supporting
black lives matter and donating to black
lives matter and I want to hear from you
about whether you believe that I am too
cynical about this issue because I don't
believe corporations supporting or not
supporting black lives matter is really
indicative of any of their moral points
of view or even necessarily of the
politics of the company these mostly our
business calculations and I'm actually
going to go even further in the analysis
this is by design we should not even
expect corporations to really function
on any basis other than how much money
is this going to make us because this is
how they are designed in particular
publicly traded corporations have a
fiduciary responsibility to their
shareholders to deliver a return and to
make money so my personal view is
corporations should be responsible to
all stakeholders now when we say
stakeholders that's bigger than
shareholders stakeholders include
society it includes the economy more
broadly it includes the environment this
is not the way corporations operates so
all sorts of different companies we've
seen you know Target Home Depot Etsy H&M
on the list of companies supporting
black lives matter
some donating to black lives matter and
affiliated causes I don't really think
it matters in terms of figuring out the
morality of these companies tons of
companies have said you know we're
committed to fighting injustice some say
they're committed to dealing with
systemic racism others are donating
money whatever now to the extent that
they're handing cash over the money can
be used to fight these battles and
that's good and the money is money no
matter who donated it but fundamentally
at the corporate level these are
business calculations I was thinking
back to my first appearance on the Joe
Rogan program we were having a
conversation about Google and Joe felt
that Google is a left-wing company
because they have a non-discrimination
policy for trans workers that includes
you you refer to people by their
preferred gender pronouns and so Joe
felt that Google was a left-wing company
on that basis my position was that a
non-discrimination policy from a human
resources standpoint doesn't really tell
us whether the company's right-wing or
left-wing in terms of its place in the
world and in fact I said to Joe Google
is part of the anti regulation avoid
taxes movement that's often more
associated with the right than the left
in the United States but the truth is
that all of this stuff has one focus how
can Google gain market share and how can
Google make more money having the LGBT
non-discrimination policy probably helps
their bottom line more than it hurts it
from a PR perspective just like lobbying
against taxes helps their bottom line
lobbying against regulation helps their
bottom line and much the same way that's
the lens through which I see this
corporate support of black lives matter
now it's important to mention I'm not
denying for a second that many of the
individuals who work at these companies
probably do support black lives matter
from a personal standpoint I am sure
that many of them oppose police
brutality I am sure that many of the
workers and even executives that these
companies agree with the protests
because most of the country agrees with
the reasons for the protests but much
like I often say we shouldn't deify
individual politicians they're just
people they're right on some things that
are wrong on some other things we should
not attribute certain agency to
corporations when all we can really say
is they've calculated their options and
have made a business decision the
business decisions might sometimes
coincide with the political feelings of
the executives you might have a
situation where the executives support
black lives matter and supporting black
lives matter is good for the company's
bottom line it's all beautiful it's all
hunky dory kumbaya and it's it's that's
the way that that it all goes down but
at no point should we lose sight of the
reality that if it were really bad for a
corporation to support black lives
matter based on their customer base and
other fact
they would be dramatically less likely
to say we support the protests or black
lives matter or are donating so tell me
what you think am I being overly cynical
here am i oversimplifying some component
of this I want to hear from you
I believe that corporate support of
black lives matter not I'm not talking
about the individuals at the company's
corporate support of black lives matter
is merely a calculated business decision
I want to hear from you we will have
more about this on our Instagram page
which is david pakman show all one word
on instagram follow us there we'll take
a quick break much more about the John
Bolton Donald Trump scandal coming up
after this short break privacy calm is
one of our sponsors and they're giving
you $5.00 just for using their free
service at privacy calm slash Pakman
privacy's of service I've been using for
a while now I love it it saves me a
bunch of headaches it's completely free
and it's very quick to set up and here's
how it works
when you pay for something online or
over the phone instead of exposing your
real credit card number privacy lets you
generate virtual card numbers the
payments are withdrawn from your
checking account but your real card
number stays completely private and you
do it all with one click you can
autofill the card number in your web
browser on the phone you can create 12
virtual cards a month you can set
spending limits freeze them delete them
whenever you want I especially love it
for free trials where you need to give a
credit card number because I can destroy
the virtual card number as soon as I
give it to the company and I know I
won't be charged in the future if you're
ordering food over the phone why do I
need to give a restaurant my real card
number I don't have to companies don't
have to know who you are your real
credit card number is protected from the
data breaches that happen unfortunately
more often than we would like and it's
completely free they do have a paid
version with different tiers where you
can create more virtual credit card
numbers per month cash back rewards
extra security features but go ahead and
sign up for the free service it's a no
brainer companies can't charge you
unexpectedly you're protected
identity theft that costs you nothing
and privacy is giving you five dollars
to spend just for signing up when you go
to privacy calm slash Pakman